.
Mit Untertiteln
von SWISS TXT
Marco Cortesi -
der bekannteste Polizist der
Deutschschweiz verlässt die Bühne.
Als Medienchef
der Zürcher Stadtpolizei
war er omnipräsent auf allen Kanälen.
Herr Cortesi,
wann hat sich die Lage beruhigt?
warum hat sich die Lage verschärft?
Herr Cortesi, gibt es Bilder
von Überwachungskameras?
Populär und zuweilen schillernd,
aber nicht unumstritten.
Von aussen gesehen muss man sagen,
dass eine Medienstelle nicht
der Fanklub der Stadtpolizei ist.
Du warst manchmal auch eine Diva,
oder? Eine Mediendiva.
Die Konfrontationen blieben.
Einsatzmittel und Taktik
wurden besser.
* Explosion *
Der Respekt vor der Polizei nahm ab.
Marco Cortesi hat sich gehalten.
Wir können uns das
von der Polizei her nicht erklären.
Wir stehen vor einem Rätsel.
Dann kann man da
immer nur so machen.
Ein Leben im Dienst der Polizei.
Interviewtermin an der Langstrasse.
Es geht um eine Corona-Kontrolle,
über die verspätet berichtet wurde.
"Mangelnde Transparenz",
so der Vorwurf.
Die "Rundschau" fragt nach.
- Ich habe sonst kein Papier.
Aber das
ist so verdammt hochpolitisch.
Sie stehen so, Herr Cortesi.
- So?- Ja.
Grundsätzlich war es so,
dass die Stadtpolizei Zürich
offen, transparent und schnell
kommunizieren wollte.
Gab es politischen Widerstand
dagegen, dass Sie informieren?
Die Polizei
hat selbstverständlich den Auftrag,
transparent und offen
zu kommunizieren,
unabhängig davon,
ob die Politik das will oder nicht.
Man weiss,
dass die Stadtpolizei Zürich
immer schnell,
offen und transparent kommuniziert.
Das wollten wir auch, aber die Zu-
ständigkeiten mussten geklärt sein.
Eine Botschaft mehrfach wiederholt -
Cortesi ganz der Profi ...
* Die Frau ruft Unverständliches. *
... es wird genauer kontrolliert?
... der sich auch durch Zwischenrufe
nicht aus der Ruhe bringen lässt.
Das kann man sicher sagen.
Man kann sagen,
dass die Polizei wirklich aktiv war,
in der Langstrasse
und in anderen Quartieren.
Gut.
Ich möchte doch noch kurz fragen:
Was war mit der los?
Sie wollte sich einfach einbringen.
- Ah!
Irgendetwas reinrufen.
- Also doch gut, dass ihr hier wart.
Herr Cortesi, was für eine Funktion
haben die beiden Polizisten?
An und für sich kamen sie mit,
damit ich nicht ganz alleine
in der Langstrasse sein muss.
Es hat sich gezeigt,
dass das richtig war.
Die Frau wurde ja etwas ausfällig.
Sie sind sicher
auch etwas im Hintergrund,
damit das Fernsehen
ein Bild von der Polizei
auf der Strasse im Kreis 4 hat.
Sie wollten das Bild ja noch, oder?
- Unbedingt.
Eben.
Mehrfach wurde Marco Cortesi
schon angegriffen.
Die Langstrasse hat in den letzten
Jahren einen anderen Ruf erhalten
als noch vor 30, 40 Jahren,
als ich hier Streifenwagen fuhr.
Hier erlebt man als Streifenpolizist
- wie meine Kollegen - am meisten.
Hier tauchte aber auch erstmals
ein Phänomen auf,
das die Polizei
bis heute beschäftigt:
Die Beamten
werden angepöbelt und angegriffen.
Die Stadtpolizei versuchte 2009
die alte Ordnung wiederherzustellen.
Einen schönen Abend! Heute Abend
läuft die Aktion "Respekt".
Die meisten von euch wissen,
um was es geht.
Wieder Respekt verschaffen,
null Toleranz, durchgreifen -
das war der Plan.
- Nein, nein.
Hände rauf.
- Ja. Fai problema?
(Original) Auf der Langstrasse
kommt der Patrouille auf der Busspur
verbotenerweise
ein Velofahrer entgegen.
Er touchiert das Polizeiauto -
oder hat er getreten?
Auf jeden Fall gibt es kein Pardon.
* Laute Rufe *
Aus der Verkehrsübertretung
wird ein polizeilicher Grosseinsatz.
Keine angenehme Aufgabe,
diesen Vorfall zu erklären.
Muss das sein? Wollen Sie das
mit der Aktion "Respekt"?
Das ist natürlich
an und für sich kleinlich.
Aber die ganze Polizeiarbeit
beruht darauf,
dass wir die Regeln
gegenseitig respektieren.
Die Regeln sind ganz klar gegeben.
Wir lassen uns nicht einfach
ans Auto treten.
Wir akzeptieren es nicht,
dass man Polizisten
anspuckt, anrempelt oder angreift.
Deshalb schaffen wir hier
einfach wieder Respekt.
Die Bilder gaben zu reden.
Heute ist klar:
Die Aktion war ein Flop.
Ich glaube, dass das Wort "Respekt"
schon mal falsch war.
Und dann geriet dadurch die ganze
Aktion ein bisschen ins Stocken.
Ich glaube, man hätte dort
auch andere Wege gehen können,
um gleich viel zu erreichen.
- Was denn?
Den Dialog,
den wir nachher wirklich suchten,
dass man miteinander spricht.
Ich denke, das ist der richtige Weg.
Marco Cortesi
wurde das Gesicht dieses neuen Stils.
* Ruhige Musik *
So ...
Arbeitsbeginn vor 7 Uhr
in der Urania-Wache.
Es wartet Routine.
Wegen Corona läuft wenig
in Marco Cortesis letzten
Arbeitstagen vor der Pensionierung.
Im Schnitt
beantwortet die Medienstelle
sonst 25'000 Telefonanrufe im Jahr
mit einem vierköpfigen Team.
Der Chef legt Wert auf Harmonie
und den gleichen Werdegang.
Ich mag es, wenn die Leute
eine Polizeiausbildung haben,
dass sie auch mal
bei der Kripo gearbeitet haben,
damit sie genau wissen,
wie eine Verhaftung läuft
und wie die Polizeiarbeit ist,
dass man Nachtdienst hat usw.
Und die Akzeptanz innerhalb
der Polizei ist sicher grösser,
wenn jemand vom Beruf her kommt.
Das Team Cortesi -
eine eingeschworene Truppe.
Du schuldest mir immer noch
das Wörterzeugs.
"Wie sprechen die Jungen?"
Das habe ich doch gemacht.
Gestern ...
* Lachen *
Gestern sagte ich in der Migros
zu einer:
"Sie, beefen wir uns?"
Die sah mich
mit so grossen Augen an:
"Was, kennen Sie das?"
Da sagte ich:
"Ja, meine Sis sagt das immer."
Da staunte sie noch mehr.
Das war lustig.
Wie jeden Tag stellt sich die Frage,
welche neuen Fälle
eine Pressemitteilung verdienen.
Im Kreis 7 wurde ein Auto
in einem Feld entdeckt.
Ein Selbstunfall mit einem Motorrad
im Kreis 10.
Und ein Verkehrsunfall zwischen ...
- Bleiben wir kurz bei dem!
Schauen wir, was damit ist?
Es klingt nicht
nach schwer verletzt.
Müssen wir nichts machen?
- Vom Spital her auch nicht.
Gut, lassen wir.
- Dann noch ein spezieller Fall:
der Mandarinenfall.
Ja, ähm ...
- Klingt schon gut.
Ja, es ist sehr speziell.
Ein Frau und ein Mann
arbeiteten zusammen
und wollten sich
eine Mandarine teilen.
Er schälte sie
und sie ging auf die Toilette.
Als sie zurückkam, fand sie, die
Mandarine sei komisch und bitter.
Sie äusserte dann den Verdacht,
der Kollege habe irgendetwas
in die Mandarine getan,
irgendeine Substanz oder so.
Da mussten wir ausrücken.
Wir haben die Mandarine aber
sichergestellt und schauen jetzt.
* Lachen *
- Ja ...
Was machen wir damit?
- Tja ...
Abwarten, was rauskommt.
Vielleicht hat sie ja recht.
Wer weiss?
Es wird sich zeigen, dass
die Mandarine nicht vergiftet war.
Von skurril bis tragisch -
Marco Cortesi hat alles erlebt.
1994:
Helikopterunglück im Triemliquartier.
(Originalkommentar)
Weder Hausbewohner noch Passanten
erlebten Verletzungen,
aber der Helipilot und der
einzige Passagier wurden getötet.
Im ersten grossen Einsatz:
Marco Cortesi.
Wer der Pilot ist,
was für eine Fluggesellschaft
ihn hierhergeführt hat
und was der Helikopter hier
zu suchen hat, wissen wir nicht.
Die Unfallursache
ist momentan auch nicht klar.
Wir warten auf das Büro
für Flugunfälle in Bern,
das die Untersuchung
dann führen wird.
Es war noch etwas holprig,
wenn ich mir das heute ansehe.
Heute wäre ich nicht zufrieden mit
meinen Mitarbeitern oder mit mir.
Die Unsicherheit
war ganz klar spürbar.
Es war das erste Mal, dass ich
so viele Mikrofone vor mir hatte.
Das macht natürlich
ein bisschen eine Blockade.
Es gibt den Mediendruck.
Das ist heute anders als damals.
Note 4 bis 5.
Nein, keine Vier.
Da hätte ich keine Vier gegeben.
Offenbar stiessen um ca. 17.45 Uhr
zwei Züge zusammen.
Ein Wagen ist entgleist.
Es gab Verletzte.
Nach ersten Informationen
sollen es
mehr als 20 verletzte Personen sein.
Jetzt schalten wir
zu Urs Schnellmann, der vor Ort ist.
Er hat einen Interviewpartner
bei sich.
Bei mir ist Marco Ca... Marco Casesi
von der Stadtpolizei Zürich.
Herr Cortesi,
gibt es offizielle Zahlen?
Was kann man sagen zu Verletzten
oder sogar einem Toten,
den es geben soll?
Darf ich unterbrechen?
Wir brauchen dich. Tut mir leid.
Ich drücke mich nicht.
- Du musst mitkommen.
Man merkt, es ist ein Chaos
hier auf der Unfallstelle.
Bis jetzt kann ich sagen ...
Hier sieht man das schön:
Das ist die Chaosphase.
Die gibt es immer.
Auch Herr Schnellmann
ist in der Chaosphase drin.
Er kann nicht mal mehr
meinen Namen richtig sagen,
obwohl er den sonst
problemlos hingekriegt hat.
Der Einsatzleiter
war in der Chaosphase.
Er liess mich einfach wegholen -
egal, wie viele Leute dort waren.
Sie sagte: "Einfach mitkommen."
Ich glaube, der Einzige,
der vernünftig reagierte, war ich.
Ich reagierte nicht gross.
Ich hätte zu ihr sagen können:
"Bist du wahnsinnig?"
In dem Moment
ärgerte mich das stark.
Das war ein Ereignis,
das ich nie mehr vergesse.
Bilder der Zerstörung.
Mit der Zeit wird klar:
Die Flankenfahrt forderte
ein Todesopfer und 45 Verletzte.
Sie machen sich selber ein Bild.
Sie gehen richtig hin.
Immer.
- Oder zählen Sie auf die Infos?
Nein, nein. Also, immer.
Ich will das sehen.
Ich will die Emotion
und Betroffenheit haben.
Das sage ich auch
meinen Mitarbeitenden immer:
"Schaut hin,
auch wenn es schlimm ist!"
Wenn sie danach einen
öffentlichen Auftritt haben ...
Es ist nicht dasselbe,
wenn einem das jemand erzählt hat.
Man muss es gesehen haben.
Solche Erlebnisse
müssen privat ausbalanciert sein.
Seit 25 Jahren ist sie
an Marco Cortesis Seite:
Brigitte Bühler,
Geschäftsleitungsmitglied
in einem Architekturunternehmen.
Sie teilt Cortesis Liebe
zu seiner Heimat, dem Engadin.
Gemeinsam
haben sie den Piz Palü bestiegen.
Das Video
hat Cortesi selber geschnitten.
(Rätoromanisch)
Ihm zuliebe hat die Zürcherin
sogar Rätoromanisch gelernt.
Weil ich einen Partner habe,
den ich sehr mag.
Irgendwann kamen wir ...
... mal irgendwie ...
... darauf. Ich fragte ein Wort
und wollte wissen,
warum das überhaupt so heisse.
So ergab sich das dann.
Der Bündner in Zürich.
War der Dialekt ein Karriere-Booster?
Der spielt sicher
eine gewisse Rolle.
Das gehört halt einfach
zum Gesamtpaket, dass ich so rede -
mit allem Drum und Dran.
Ich bin die Person und werde nie
eine andere sein können.
Ich bin froh, den Dialekt zu haben.
Käme ich aus Chur, hätte ich
noch einen viel ausgeprägteren.
Ich weiss nicht, ob das
noch die richtige Mischung wäre.
Und das Lispeln?
Das gehört halt auch dazu.
Das gehört zum Gesamtpaket.
Es wäre mir wohl lieber,
das nicht zu haben,
aber ich habe das schon 65 Jahre.
Ich werde es auch
die nächsten paar Jahre haben.
Der kleine Marco -
1956 in Samedan geboren.
Sein älterer Bruder, schwerbehindert,
stirbt früh.
Schellen-Marcos Vater arbeitet
im Tiefbauamt in leitender Position.
Erster Schultag.
Meine Mutter
machte sich immer Sorgen,
wenn das Telefon klingelte.
Sie dachte: "Oh, jetzt hat Marco
wieder irgendetwas angestellt."
Lausbubenstreiche:
Portemonnaie wegziehen,
mit Spiegeln Leute blenden
und mit Luftgewehren
auf Vögel schiessen.
Nichts Gravierendes,
nichts Straffälliges.
Cortesi als 16-Jähriger.
Was haben Sie in diesen Jahren
beruflich gemacht?
Nichts.
Ski fahren und Golf spielen.
Das ist auch nicht nichts,
aber etwas wenig.
Dann ging ich zur Post,
machte eine Postlehre.
Dann dachte ich, man könnte
vielleicht noch etwas mehr machen.
Eine Freundin schlägt vor,
er solle doch zur Polizei.
Und tatsächlich: Mit 28
tritt Cortesi die Polizeischule an.
Es konnte sich niemand vorstellen,
dass ich mal zur Polizei gehe.
Aber der Spätzünder kämpft sich hoch,
setzt sich beharrlich
gegen Widersacher durch,
wird als Polizeisprecher
zum Medienstar.
Wenn ich mein Leben anschaue,
hätte es für mich
nicht besser sein können.
Ich konnte alles erfüllen,
was ich wollte.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden,
wenn ich zurückschaue.
Ich muss sagen,
dass ich sehr viel Glück hatte.
Ich traf immer auf Menschen,
die es gut mit mir meinten.
Nicht zu dünn!
Effektiv.
- Ja.
Au!
* Sie lacht. *
Jetzt kannst wieder übernehmen,
Fräulein.
Rührst du lieber?
Ich habe das mega gut gemacht.
Jetzt kannst du.
* Ruhige Jazzmusik *
Viva.
- Viva.
Auf einen Fall
ist Marco Cortesi besonders stolz.
Am Tag nach dem Zürcher Millionen-
Kunstraub in der Bührle-Sammlung
läuft die Fahndung auf Hochtouren.
Die Nachricht geht um die Welt:
In einem filmreifen Coup
reissen Räuber im Bührle-Museum
vier Bilder von der Wand.
Es sind viele Leute hier.
Wir teilen
in drei, vier Gruppen auf.
Nur ein paar Schritte nach links
im Parterre
hingen die Bilder an der Wand.
Gesichert
waren sie nur mit Bewegungsmeldern.
Bisher wissen wir,
dass die drei Täter maskiert
und bewaffnet in den Raum kamen.
Man zwang das Personal,
sich auf den Boden zu legen.
Zwei der Täter
gingen schnurstracks rein
und hängten
ein Bild nach dem anderen ab.
Es ist der grösste Kunstraub
in der Geschichte Europas.
Man muss davon ausgehen, dass sie
genau wussten, was sie wollten.
(Übersetzung)
The paintings are so well known
that they can't really
do anything with them.
(Originalkommentar) Die Beute:
ein Degas im Wert von 10 Mio. Fr.,
ein Monet für 20 Mio. Fr.,
"Kastanienzweige" von van Gogh
für 50 Mio. Fr.
und "Der Knabe mit der roten Weste"
von Cézanne für 100 Mio. Fr.
Heute sind alle Kunstwerke zurück
an einem diebstahlsicheren Ort.
Schon ein Wunder,
dass die wieder da sind.
Es ist super. Unglaublich!
Der Direktor der Sammlung Bührle,
Lukas Gloor,
hat uns in ein
schwer gesichertes Lager geführt,
irgendwo im Raum Zürich.
Als ich Herrn Gloor
zum ersten Mal traf
und er sagte,
das habe so einen Wert, dachte ich:
"Der spinnt!"
"Der glaubt das wirklich!"
Die Fahndung beginnt holprig,
obwohl klar ist,
wie das Täterauto aussieht.
Wir machten einen Radius von 2 km
um das Bührle-Museum
und schickten alle Polizistinnen
und Polizisten aus,
um nach einem weissen Auto
zu suchen.
Sie sollten
die Autonummern aufschreiben
und in die Autos reinschauen.
Es gab jemanden,
der zwar sehr gute Augen hatte,
die Nummern der Autos aufschrieb,
aber nicht reinschaute.
Das war wirklich ein Flop,
das muss man sagen.
Nicht Stadtpolizei-Zürich-like.
So vergeht eine Woche,
bis beim Burghölzli zwei der
gestohlenen Bilder gefunden werden.
Ein Klinik-Angestellter
entdeckte die Bilder,
weil er den gebührenpflichtigen
Parkplatz regelmässig kontrolliert.
Wir dürfen und wollen
aber nicht vergessen,
dass zwei weitere Bilder
unserer Sammlung weiterhin fehlen.
Ab 16 Uhr stehen Ihnen
auch Medienmitteilungen
in englischer
und französischer Sprache
auf unserer Homepage zur Verfügung.
Marco Cortesi
im Zentrum der Aufmerksamkeit.
Aber die Ermittlungen
werden noch vier Jahre dauern.
2012: Diese Bilder
veröffentlicht die serbische Polizei.
Dank Unterstützung aus Zürich
schnappt die Falle zu.
Der millionenschwere
"Knabe mit der roten Weste"
hat das Abenteuer gut überstanden.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht nur
für die Stadtpolizei Zürich,
sondern für die Polizei schlechthin,
in ganz Europa oder auf der Welt,
der grösste Erfolg,
den man haben konnte:
dass man Bilder in dem Wert und auch
die Täter dingfest machen konnte,
die wirklich
keine mutmasslichen sind.
Sie wurden auch verurteilt.
Man konnte alles sicherstellen.
Und am Schluss
stehen die Bilder wieder hier.
Bald haben die Täter
ihre Haft abgesessen.
Die Ermittler befürchten Racheakte.
Ein wahrer Krimi.
So viel wie bei diesem Fall
habe ich selten gelernt.
Als ich das erste Mal kam,
wusste ich nicht mal, wie man
"Degas" oder "Cézanne" schreibt.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung.
Aber heute habe ich doch eine ganz
andere Beziehung zu den Bildern.
Die Werke der Sammlung Bührle
werden ab Herbst
in diesem Erweiterungsbau
des Kunsthauses zu sehen sein.
Der Kunstraub - ein Jahrhundertfall.
Wiederkehrend dagegen
die Querelen um den 1. Mai.
Auf die friedliche Demonstration
folgten immer wieder Ausschreitungen.
Diese Bilder
sind mehr als zehn Jahre alt.
Gewaltbereite Demonstranten,
Chaoten und Mitläufer
liefern sich im Langstrassenquartier
im Zürcher Kreis 4
ein Katz-und-Maus-Spiel
mit der Polizei.
Flaschen fliegen, Container brennen,
es gibt Festnahmen.
Mit diesen Steinen
wurden Polizistinnen und Polizisten
angegriffen.
Es ist ein reines Wunder,
dass es
keine schweren Verletzungen gab.
Warum die Leute das machen,
weiss ich nicht.
Für mich
ist das nicht nachvollziehbar.
Es ist unglaublich, was da abging,
diese Zerstörungswut,
was Randalierer
alles machen konnten.
Die Polizei hat inzwischen
ganz andere taktische Einsatzmittel.
Man kann Einsätze
viel besser steuern und lenken.
Wir können die Leute und Fahrzeuge
tracken.
Wir wissen genau, wo ein Auto ist.
Der Einsatzleiter
sieht im Einsatzraum genau,
wo die Leute platziert sind
und wo die Autos stehen.
Dadurch kann er viel, viel schneller
Verschiebungen vornehmen,
als er das vorher
mit Magneten konnte.
Dementsprechend ist das,
was vor zehn Jahren möglich war,
jetzt nicht mehr möglich.
Einkesseln und abwürgen -
die Taktik heute.
Auch das Thema Waffen
beschäftigt Cortesi immer wieder.
Gross das Interesse der Medien.
Das sind z.T. Stellmesser.
Dann hat es v.a.
sehr viele pistolenähnliche Waffen.
Airsoft guns.
Hier sehen wir eine fünfschüssige
Schusswaffe, getarnt als Messer.
In der Stadt Zürich
haben wir immer mehr
auch mit sehr gefährlichen Waffen
zu tun, z.B. so einer Pump-Action.
In letzter Zeit
leider auch immer wieder Waffen,
die verdeckt und getarnt
getragen werden,
wie z.B. dieser kleine Revolver,
der äusserst gefährlich ist,
in so einem Gürtel drin.
Bitte schön.
Wir besuchen die Waffensammlung
der Stadtpolizei.
Hier werden beschlagnahmte
und vereinzelt neu gekaufte Waffen
für Schulungszwecke und
ballistische Abklärungen aufbewahrt.
Klar ist: Der Waffengebrauch
hat sich verändert.
Was man sicher sagen kann, ist,
dass natürlich Tötungsdelikte
mit Schusswaffen ...
... extrem abgenommen haben.
Wenn ich früher ausrückte,
lagen da vier, fünf
mit Schussverletzungen am Boden.
Heute kommt das gar nicht mehr vor,
dass eine Schusswaffe
eingesetzt wird.
Aber sehr viele Stichwaffen
mit gravierenden Verletzungen.
Auch die Messer
werden geordnet und gehortet.
Die sind alle verboten,
die einhändigen, oder?
Nein, das ist vorbei. Das war mal.
- Das ist vorbei?
Einhändig ist kein Kriterium mehr,
nur noch automatisch.
Auch noch gut:
so eine Steinschleuder.
Hochleistungssteinschleuder.
Heute verboten mit diesem Bügel.
Umgekehrt.
- Umgekehrt.
Das hättest du auf dem Arm.
- Ah, so!
So hast du eine grosse Zugkraft.
- Da kannst du natürlich ...
Jetzt könntest du unten reingreifen,
dann wärst du bereit.
Aha, so.
Die Todeskralle.
So ein Scheiss!
Immer war Marco Cortesi bemüht,
die Fachgebiete seiner Kollegen
ins beste Licht zu rücken.
Show machen wir eigentlich nicht.
Aber man kann natürlich
gewisse Sachen
mit dem Auge viel besser erkennen,
wenn ich etwas zeigen kann,
seien das Steine oder Eisenstangen,
die auf uns geworfen wurden.
Wenn ich so einen Pollerstein habe,
ist das etwas ganz anderes,
als wenn ich das einfach sage.
Mit einer Imitationswaffe
kann ich das nur so zeigen
und fragen,
ob man den Unterschied sehe.
Das kann niemand.
Das kann einfach niemand.
Ich versuche immer, etwas zu zeigen,
zu jeder Aussage ein Bild zu machen.
Dann kann man etwas verstehen.
Ob Waffen, 3D-Scanner
oder virtuelle Ausbildung -
Cortesi bringt die Stadtpolizei
immer wieder in die Medien.
Das ist natürlich
wahnsinnig faszinierend.
Wir sind immer
auf dem neusten Stand.
Wir haben immer das Beste
und Neuste.
Jetzt aber.
Mit dieser Begeisterung
für alle Polizeibelange
stösst Marco Cortesi
allerdings auch auf Ablehnung.
Ich glaube, dass Marco Cortesi
in der Zeit als Mediensprecher
mit Leib und Seele
zum Stadtpolizisten wurde,
ein richtiger Fan der Stadtpolizei.
Als Mitarbeitender
hält man ihm das wohl zugute.
Von aussen gesehen muss man sagen,
dass eine Medienstelle
nicht der Fanklub der Abteilung ist.
Dort hätte ich mir manchmal
eine nüchternere, sachlichere
und auch faktenbezogenere
Kommunikation gewünscht.
Auch die Polizei
war nicht immer zufrieden mit ihm.
Das weiss seine ehemalige
politische Vorgesetzte.
Herr Cortesi war auch häufig
unter Druck des Korps.
Das Korps wollte wissen:
"Warum hast du das so gesagt?"
"Warum hast du
die Kritik geäussert?"
Das Korps
hätte gerne jemanden gehabt,
der immer alles schönredet.
Das hat er nicht gemacht.
Er stand auch bei mir im Büro
und sagte,
so könne man es nicht sagen
und nicht machen.
Er war auf beide Seiten kritisch und
kam von beiden Seiten unter Druck.
Du warst manchmal auch eine Diva,
oder?
Eine Mediendiva.
Daher musste man miteinander
einen Weg suchen.
Die "Diva" ist mir im Hinterkopf.
Die kriege ich jetzt sicher
von ihr zu hören.
Das Wort "Diva" ist natürlich ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Als das fühle ich mich nicht.
Eine Diva ist für mich eher eine,
die schnell beleidigt ist,
wenn irgendetwas ist.
Das war ich nicht.
Tatsache ist:
Cortesi hat sich über die Jahre
einen Spielraum erarbeitet,
wie ihn kein anderer Berufskollege
hat.
Und Tatsache ist: Marco Cortesi
scheut das Rampenlicht nicht.
Ob Spontanauftritt im Zirkus
oder Einsatz
für eine Bühnenproduktion -
der Medienchef der Stadtpolizei fühlt
sich unter den Leuten sichtlich wohl.
Selbst als Schauspieler tritt er auf.
(Stotternd)
Hey, w-wo-wo sind sie h-hin?
Wer?
Die, die mir d-den Hut
ge-k-k-klaut haben.
Am Set
des deutschen Krimis "Borchert"
überwacht Cortesi den
Statisteneinsatz der Stadtpolizei.
Mit der Schauspielerei
ist es vorbei, trotz reger Nachfrage.
Zuerst war ich ein Verletzter
im Rollstuhl,
dann spielte ich
in "Mein Name ist Eugen" eine Rolle.
Dann hätte ich in "Grounding"
noch eine spielen sollen.
Dann sagte das Kommando aber Nein:
"Entweder bist du unser Sprecher
oder Schauspieler."
"Beides geht nicht."
Und das war auch richtig.
Hier sieht es Marco Cortesi
auch als seine Aufgabe,
Fehler im Krimi zu verhindern.
Das Absperrband z.B.
ist falsch gespannt.
Dass es hier ...
Das Band eher auf diese Seite nehmen
oder da hinten.
Einfach nicht ...
Die Rettungsachse muss frei bleiben.
Okay.
Bei uns hätte der da
die Schuhe auch weiss.
Auch? Alles weiss?
- Alles weiss.
Der hinterlässt mit diesen Schuhen
natürlich auch Spuren.
Original Polizeischuhüberzieher
für die Schauspieler.
Das sieht sonst scheisse aus.
- Gut, super. Merci.
Der Kopf wäre halt eben auch ...
Ich habe keinen.
- Keinen?
Ich glaube nicht.
- Sie können den anziehen.
Okay.
Wechseln?
- Ja. Haben Sie die Kappe an?
Ja, ich glaube.
- Sie müssen die Haare ...
Die Haare da rein.
- Ich muss sie zusammenbinden.
Haare geben ganz viele Spuren.
Kapuze auch rauf.
- Ja, mache ich gleich.
Jetzt sieht es dann gut aus.
Danke.
Ready and Action.
Die Polizisten
stehen in ihrer Freizeit im Einsatz
und erhalten eine Statistengage.
Marco Cortesi ist zufrieden.
Alles hat seine Richtigkeit.
Privat interessieren ihn Krimis
allerdings nicht, sagt er.
Sein Berufsalltag
bringt genug Spannung.
2007:
Brand im Zunfthaus zur Zimmerleuten.
(Originalkommentar) Die Feuerwehr
trifft kurz nach dem Alarm
mit einem Grossaufgebot ein.
100 Feuerwehrleute sind im Einsatz.
Viel retten können sie nicht mehr.
Es war tatsächlich so,
dass die Flammen bereits meterhoch
aus dem Dach kamen.
Was man zu diesem Zeitpunkt
nicht weiss:
Beim Einsturz des Dachstocks kommt
es zu einem verhängnisvollen Unfall:
Ein 44-jähriger Feuerwehrmann,
der im dritten Stock löscht,
wird von Dachbalken
so schwer getroffen,
dass er noch auf dem Brandplatz
stirbt.
Das war eine schwierige Nacht.
Es war im November.
Es war extrem kalt.
Dann sagte mir der Einsatzleiter
der Feuerwehr,
ich könne doch sicher
mit denen reden.
Ich sagte, das könne ich schon.
Dann trafen wir uns im Rüden,
im Eingangsbereich.
Dort standen 25 Feuerwehrmänner
mit z.T. schwarzen Gesichtern
und Tränen in den Augen.
Da merkte ich, dass mir
die richtigen Worte fehlten,
dass ich das nicht kann.
Ich wusste nicht,
was ich denen sagen könnte.
Marco Cortesi für einmal sprachlos.
Unzählige Erinnerungen
verbinden ihn mit der Stadt Zürich.
Ende Januar ist Schluss.
Den Chefposten
wird seine langjährige Stell-
vertreterin Judith Hödl übernehmen.
Letzten Juli hatte sie
einen grossen Auftritt im Zoo,
als ein Tiger eine Tierpflegerin
tödlich attackierte.
Es finden Befragungen
und eine Spurensicherung statt,
aber momentan wissen wir nicht mehr.
Ich bin sicher eine andere Person.
Mir ist klar, dass es grosse Fuss-
stapfen sind, die er hinterlässt.
Ich bin anders. Ich bin eine Frau.
Das ist etwas völlig anderes.
Das gab es in Zürich noch nie,
eine Medienchefin.
Ähm ...
Ich kann im Moment noch nicht sagen,
wie das kommt,
aber ich denke,
es ist immer das Schlechteste,
wenn man versucht,
jemanden zu kopieren.
Das ist nie gut.
Marco Cortesi will als Kommunika-
tionsberater im Geschäft bleiben.
Und doch
sieht er seiner Pensionierung
nicht ganz entspannt entgegen.
Mein Leben wird sich sehr verändern,
das ist mir bewusst.
Das weiss ich schon seit Längerem.
Der Bedeutungsverlust
gehört sicher auch dazu.
Aber ich werde nach wie vor
Marco Cortesi sein -
ob ich hier arbeite oder nicht.
Aber es wird sich in meinem Leben
sicher einiges ändern.
Mehr Engadin, ist sicher ein Ziel,
mehr biken, weniger Termine.
Aber für alle
ist Cortesi ohne Polizei
und die Polizei ohne Cortesi
zurzeit noch schwer vorstellbar.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021